my name is Auggie Pullman
next week I start fifth grade and since
I've never been to a real school before
and pretty much totally petrified I'll
see you later
thank you you don't want to walk up with
your parents because it's not cool but
you're cool I know I am but technically
most dad's arms neither of these helmets
dear God please make them be nice
[Music]
I know I'm not an ordinary Kendall kid
I've had 27 surgeries they told me to
breathe to see here without hearing aids
but none of them have made me look
ordinary incubator Bunsen burners oh and
this is an eraser you know what an
eraser is spray cookies face yours
anything that'll be my life I look like
him I'd swear I'd put a hood over my
face I know you don't always like it but
I love it
it slices on its face you are not ugly
Auggie you're my mom because I'm your
mom it counts the most because I know
you the most you don't have to do this I
don't know what you're talking about
you don't have to put ten days on saying
Auggie okay I'm really sorry why you
shouldn't hear them someone say those
friends for a change
okay who is it that I aspire to be that
is the question that we should be asking
ourselves all the time
hey Jack come sit here in a sec
I'd like to be able to control the
weather about what the Year superpower
that sounds pretty lame oh what'd you do
I'm being visible you're the toughest
kid in that school
show them we can't blend in when you
were born to stand out
[Music]
never thought about having plastic
surgery
dude this is after plastic surgery it
takes a lot of work slip the skin
[Music]
you
you